et dans un instant bien sûr on aura
camille combal qui viendra nous voir
avec le tuto de matthieu delormeau
comment jouer ça vous fait les en pleine
émission le gars il se fait les ont
battus ce week-end que se passe
concernant la fraîche à demain il va
tout va oui oui je vois que c'est
surtout voir mon poing dans votre gueule
mais ça c'est la chaille roulettes il ya
tout le monde celui qui va être désigné
par là où même moi j'y suis regardez je
suis là là entre la danse et la gencive
je vous le dis celui qui perdra il se
mettra dedans il y aura des choses qui
vont tomber
je vous le dis il ya il ya une seule
boîte qui contient des trucs cool et
hitachi il ya six shy'm box d'accord ok
attention il faut faire tourner la roue
que shine plat qu'est-ce que vous êtes
tout simplement parce que j'ai un petit
peu et ça comme ça que vous êtes en
train de dire le blue origin est là
c'est pour avoir la la la le plaisir de
voir shy'm debout et c'est pas mal
la main
aujourd'hui
il en a qui trouvent s'exporter et non à
franchir ce pas
mais je suis en passion de ce qu'elle
fait non mais faut qu'il faut vous
habiller l'aimé bien mais je suis un
drop de chat et dr isabelle morini-bosc
con à dire mais ça arrive parce que lci
edith piaf qu'il a un qu'il arrive c'est
parti allez on y va
fly one two three
à
aïe
je vais vous dire je vous jure qu'on n'a
pas s'extraire juste avant j'avais là où
n'est pas truquée je vous sur les rails
est-ce que vous rappeler cette phrase
dans la chèvre quand y'a un moment le
gars qui fait c'est pas toujours à votre
ami et la locale eu réponse est jamais
son nom mais aujourd'hui c'est pas du
tout son genre et à son père
quant à la nature i'm on va tout de
suite joué à la boule d'achat
on va regret mais chan bob sa visite
alors il à faire financer avec tes
pattes serpent pas la secte bois de
charpente vous inquiétez pas allez bonne
année matures les verts si bonne année
allez on y va
je vais poser des questions à shy'm
within à la lâcheté et les attouchements
attention donc matthieu delormeau je
vais vous poser des questions sur shine
d'accord dès que vous commettez une
erreur shy'm choisira une boxe ici c'est
la shy'm box d'accord faire parler mon
bon du coup alors je vous le dis il ya
des crocodiles l1 et crocodiles
les bonbons et bonbons et les crocodiles
d'accord ça c'est la boîte coule
d'accord c'est la boîte coule je
regarderai avance qu'il y a d'accord pas
de serpents serpent à 6 merde qua non à
ya des serpents
non non c'est bien des serpents mais
c'est un petit nous nous n'est non
puisque c'était petit serpent c'est
comme des non des bonbons mais ça c'est
rien ça se court dans le slip c'est rien
c'est parti attention questions sur
shy'm si vous vous trompez choisira une
shine box c'est lui qui répond matthieu
delormeau matthieu delormeau souplesse
et c'est pas bientôt fini
y en a qui voudraient téléphonez
à
j'avais toutes mes chances au bund est
derrière chambre attention que signifie
l'onem et aux mails me regarde là ici
dans les yeux c'est facile que signifie
le m2 shy'm à malices b malgache c'est
martinique où des matthieu delormeau
martinique n'est pas tricher
non j'en dors sous le nom et je prends
pas juré le donnait à l'eau sur la tête
du pakistan quel beau pays je n'ai pas
triché
c'est pas toujours à demander un truc
après oh je vous entends pas et que je
vous emmerde
oui c'est bien c'est bien martinique
bien joué
aller puisque ce que child a bien sûr de
martinique voilà sinon on est au québec
stephen mais combien mais on a fait six
voulait partir et partir
ace combat oui c'est un détail mais
comme j'avais dit que je donnais c'est
shy'm ya des gens sur twitter qui me
croyais pas et qui m'ont un peu genre tu
te la pètes donc je voulais juste savoir
si ça voulait dire
je sois garde-moi trader je vous le coup
dans la gueule et retournez vous
attendez vous vous êtes beaucoup plus
beau comme ça en plus confiance bah si
je vous fais confiance
0e retournez-vous compléter ces paroles
de la chanson est alors de shy'm et
alors mais qu'est ce que ça te fait si
j'ose les copier coller les décolletés
les cravates ou les ne pas aller 3
secondes maintenant ça va bien les
décolletés les décolletés attention
vérification solar
et allah alors shy'm vous allez choisir
une boîte et c'est moi qui vais la
[ __ ] dans la bouche tanga 7 6 non vous
êtes sur la 3d regarde quoi c'est quoi
c'est rien ou mathieu sait rien mais
c'est un ami de shy'm je vais la montrer
à la caméra lescoules regarde pas le
match le retour je regardais pas si on
peut couper leurs photos coupet le
retour est cool je vais la montrer au
téléspectateur probable shui
ouais c'est vous qui avez choisi la
boîte c'est vous qui allez lui verser
bah oui un à grenay vous allez montez
pas là c'est rien c'est rien allez-y
sans risque attention troupes et attend
déjà truc à lui dire brest
c'est mon chagrin de les voler
gt rien c'est rien c'est rien d'avoir
tourné pas
j'espère tout va bien je passe
maintenant
sortait vraiment juger leur parler
s'il vous plaît les serpents c'est
quelqu'un qui a beaucoup souffert dans
sa liste un empire d'nrj 12 mois
la sorte et oui les deux mariés ou
bâlois si je passe la tête et qui me
comment charmer nos bras
il n'est pas derrière non mais ça a un
coût j'aime venir le chercher
non mais pas prendre part la non pas
quoi attendre et a comme toi devant
n'ont même pas une merde
oui
bravo
tout ce que je vais chez huawei on fait
une émission fait l'émission oui là
didon des gentils bac s carey mois sont
liés en plus je trouve pas à ce jeu pas
critiquer mais c'est quand même shy'm
d'accord vous dégâts c'est qu'a réussi à
tourner la roue et je vous dis